and then with some cuties that came in
there too and I thought yeah hey I'm
Rachel and I'm a former Starbucks
barista my name is Megan and I'm a
current Starbucks employee hi I'm Macy
and I'm a former Starbucks barista I am
CEO I'm a former Starbucks employee and
we're gonna be answering your questions
about whatever you want to know about
silence and do you make any Starbucks
two drinks at home yes so basically it's
my like bootleg version of Starbucks
because they have like all types of like
different creamers that you can buy from
the grocery store so like white and Loco
so it's always my favorite it's
basically just a creamer adorable coffee
but that's my you know Starbucks take it
home I go to Starbucks every single
morning so no I let them make it for me
I try to make like replicas using what I
have so like I called it it's like a
poor man's mocha is like my brewed
coffee that I make at home and then I
put a hot chocolate packet in my coffee
and it tastes like a mocha
I'll make caramel macchiatos oh but it's
also just it's also like you need to
have like the syrup in your house you
need to have all this other stuff and
things like that
ooh what's the worst strength you've
ever been asked to make some people
would want so many pumps of syrup or
like extra extra extra caramel it would
be a drink that like is a normal drink
but they wanted it water mic water-based
so you're mixing like water with syrups
and water with powders instead of like
milk but this would be like water with
like matcha or water with vanilla bean
powder has there ever been a customer at
your store that everyone who works here
can't stand a family a Hufflepuff
absolutely he was the most unpleasant
human being I've probably ever met
everybody we just be like alright Reds
here that was just cold word red brick
right friend there
all right just get to put on your best
you know basically force field because
he's good at me shoot you out for no
reason Meister had a lot of awful
customers so it was dependent on like
what kind of awful you were like there
were certain people who would come in
throw money on the counter and wouldn't
say worth and I loved them but then
there were other customers that was like
if I saw them in the parking lot you
wanted to have their drink ready because
I want you out of the store as quick as
possible
we call her half blonde half dark
because obviously she wants him to want
coffee and half dark coffee in her own
personal cup that's like this big but
she only wants to pay for it tall when
you're like doing the machine and you're
like okay half blonde half dark she's
like that's more blog than there is dark
can you pour it on read and I'm like has
anyone ever asked to take a picture with
you no one has ever asked to take a
picture with me but I will say that yeah
I saw this woman take a picture of my
coworker today and it was like they were
like in close vicinity so it wasn't like
it was like trying to sneak it she had
just like is like blatantly like wow
wait what what does that to do it
started my life aren't start well I it
seemed like while you were here why I
bet if you worked at like the one in
Seattle oh my god I would ask them to
take a picture oh I get it now it would
be all ages from like the high school
kids like hey you know can you get a
picture at I'm just like oh like I got
my Starbucks at like it's a really long
line like you could you know if you want
to snap one real quick you can but like
I just never really understood it what
was your favorite part or is your
favorite part about working at the
co-workers just made it like that much
easy like okay I got my boy here but
girls managers everybody was just cool
young hip we'd go out and just hang out
or whatever so I was like the best part
this is gonna make me sound like I'm
very antisocial but I actually really
love doing the dishes free coffee free
coffee and more free coffee everything
Rachel was in she's somewhere get
serviced but I loves it there so much
okay what was my favorite how are the
customers I became like so close with
them and
coworkers why do Starbucks baristas
hates making frappuccinos I mean I was a
Starbucks barista in Arizona mmm in the
summer Oh like people would come when
early a family would come and block ten
Frappuccino just right like oh my god we
only have three blenders this is gonna
take like so yeah I just don't enjoy
making them because I mean everything's
like right in front of you with the hot
bar and like you have all your pumps and
you can pretty much make everything
right here the frappuccinos are like all
the way back here so then I have to stop
like being able to like do at least two
to three drinks at one time which you're
supposed to I have to take my stuff and
go over to the frappuccinos and then
just be at the front Pacino section
which has nothing but only frappuccinos
and like maybe a couple other like cold
bar stuff which strings do you think you
make best I don't know if I make it the
best but my favorite drink to make where
the hot ones because I felt like I was
like a little scientist brewed coffee as
long as you just tell me you like a
garage a pike and I go over there like
easy done my favorite who drinks I was
the best out is the people that I knew
the best or like the people who told me
exactly what they wanted I was actually
gonna say that the frappuccinos where my
favorite you're really what's the
biggest things customers complain about
everything everything honestly a little
bit of everything it could be the drinks
it can be blind it can be the price
difference a lot of times people
complain about the price which I didn't
make that up just so you know it'll be
down to like too much whipped cream not
enough whipped cream
not enough caramel the temperatures way
too hot but you didn't say you wanted it
kids temp
I feel like people didn't tend to
complain but if they did it was more
about the drink like oh this is a ha ha
for like oh you it's too sweet it's not
sweet enough it's like you made a
different in some way but I feel like it
was brilliant
personally was a partner beginning I
didn't even think about the drinks being
a complaint I was like no I made the
drinks perfect do people eat the display
food my store no I see some stores
sometimes pull out of the display food
and I'm just like I don't want to eat
the food that like has been chillin all
day people hate the display of food when
I was there because it wasn't it was
like every but it was also like
everything was displayed too
it was like we didn't have one of each
that was left in there for three days it
was like we've had it out in the morning
we'd have like just little paring so it
was like okay you have the lemon loaf
with this that pears live with that or
like a piece of the chocolate chip
cookie so you did have plenty of people
no matter how long it was sitting there
they like kind of keep coming or you
have a kid and be like thank you and
like grab the whole thing and just run
off I guess they didn't realize if
people like to display food my Starbucks
but there was like sandwiches and yogurt
parfaits and stuff like that then at the
end of the night if they were gonna
expire then you could take them home and
then any ones that no one wanted we
don't take to a homeless shelter down
the street have you ever had a favorite
customer I am so I feel like I have like
a handful of my favorite customers and
everyone always knows because they're
like up here comes Megan's favorite
human it was this guy that was really
sweet that would come one time he like
hold my manager aside and told him that
like every day when he sees me it just
makes his day and like I'm only so happy
and smiley or whatever and then because
of that my manager gave me this like
special card oh and it was a good big
deal he remember it's a big deal yeah I
definitely had like a big smile on my
face when it was specific and then with
some cuties that came in there too now I
just act naturally
ah so what kind of jerk you gonna get to
be I definitely I like a couple of
favorite customers I'm still friends at
them on Facebook like I chat with some
of them like I definitely had a few
people I keep in touch with like their
kids and stuff like that do people
always freak out about the holiday cups
there are multiple customers that
we did freak out for having like
Christmas cups or Thanksgiving or
specific like actual named holidays of
that actual time so they just was like
okay well from I don't know if it was
September to December or if it was
October to December I forgot but one of
them's like holiday cups and that's it
it's gonna be neutral colors people
actually do freak out about them though
people would come in and like this
summer and ask if like we had any idea
like what the cups were gonna look like
and I was like I don't I'm like you care
yeah like I didn't know I said it was
such a big deal and then I think like
the first year I worked there and came
out in the news and I was like oh my god
I was like a teenager I was like people
care about this stuff I do remember a
couple people and I just remember being
like I'm not sure what side you're on
right now like I'm not sure if you're
for the cups or against the cups like
all I know is that you're shouting at me
and I'm a little confused and we've got
Christmas music playing in your kiln
Mahmood I'm glad I got to like relieve
your brains and answer some of these
questions cuz I mean these are things
that people ask me all the time
Starbucks was definitely my most
favorite job for sure and all this stuff
made me remember they're like all the
different things about them I mean even
just what you're saying about like being
able to wash the dishes in the act happy
to answer these questions that some of
you guys have probably been thinking
about for a very long time every time
you go into Starbucks I really loved
working there and literally anyone who
works with me can tell you I go there
every single day to this day so I have a
lot of love and respect for my Starbucks
it's good when you leave a job that is
like food and beverage and you still go
there afterwards like it's clean too
[Music]
you
[Music]